deep within Antarctica's icy terrain lie
half a dozen mountains that few climbers
have summited one group decided to scale
all six something no one had ever done
before they completed the expedition in
less than 10 days last month we showed
you a preview of the footage they
captured and now only on CBS this
morning here's even more video of their
amazing feet
[Music]
I've been like pretty afraid of
Antarctica in a way you know it just
seems so cold and so crazy you gotta
find you gotta go at the end of the
earth to find a place to go climbing
these days every single discipline of
climbing
[Music]
it is otherworldly
le scary face climbing
so cold
it's hard to put the words out for you :
[Music]
it's just outrageous look where I am
[Music]
I'm a camel the
[Music]
Conrad Anker cedar right and Alex
Honnold are three of the all-star North
Face climbers who recently returned from
Antarctica welcome to all of you this is
amazing yes this could be bad
yeah Conrad you came up with this idea
why this particular combination of
mountains I visited this range 21 years
ago with my late friend Alex Lowe and it
was an inspiration that story came out
in February 1998 with Nat Geo and at
that time cedar was sort of finding his
way in climbing yeah I saw it was I
think yeah about 20 20 years ago I saw
this issue of National Geographic with
Conrad Anker on the cover and I barely
just started climbing and I remember
seeing that the amazing magazine article
and thinking wow it's like they're like
astronauts it's like they went to space
or something you know it's just such a
otherworldly an outrageous environment
and I thought someday it would be
amazing to go there and climb in that
crazy place and Alex when you're there
do you feel that way when your hand is
touching the granite do you think no
human hand has ever touched here oh it
may never again is that or are you just
thinking about the next handhold no yeah
I thought about that a little bit for
sure even just skiing out of camp every
day it feels like real exploration you
know it feels so remote you're really
out there so everything we find most of
the things we climbed were brand news
and we were aware that nobody's ever
tried it before and Alex a lot of people
became familiar with your skills last
summer because you were the first person
in history to solo climb yosemite z'
famed el capitan without ropes first of
all congratulations on that how did this
compare well this is a wildly different
experience free soloing al Capitan was
something that I prepared for for almost
10 years this expedition was more of a
true adventure with friends cedar net
were mostly climbing together we were
roped together so there was safety
equipment and it was more wild more
unknown climbing I'll cap I rehearsed
quite a bit and it was all it was all
known but it was quite a bit more
difficult
cedar tell me about your it's cold
you're right yeah fingertips are so
crucial and yet
I mean how did you do it without what
happens if your hands freezing then you
can't yeah no I mean it's you know it
never goes above freezing in Antarctica
and dealing with the cold is like one of
the major struggles of climbing down
there and one of the big questions we
had was you know how are we gonna be
able to climb Rock which really requires
bare hands to climb in such an extreme
environment and what we found was that
using our speed climbing tactics that we
learned in Yosemite Valley that we were
able to climb continuously and therefore
actually climb with bare hands
in sub-freezing temperatures and and it
was pretty comfy yeah because one of you
on the table says you can't even
describe how cold it is because I'm
thinking when it hits around ten degrees
here I'm thinking I should stay home a
coat or a scarf so psychologically are
you thinking warm thoughts or what are
you doing no but in a lot of ways ten
degrees here is colder than than
Antarctica because then Arctic at least
is 24 hours of sunlight most of the time
and so if the rock is in the Sun the
rock does sort of bake a little bit
starts to radiate a little bit of warmth
it's um I don't know I mean walking
around New York I get pretty cold - yeah
but like the the second you go that the
rock goes into the shade it's like a
whole different world and it's like it's
really like serious really fast
you said there's a difference between
exploration and adventure what do you
mean because they both sound very
similar - yeah great question
exploration is this quest for knowledge
and humans have been driven by it and
that's why we're the dominant species on
this planet and it's been - what's on
the other side the river other side the
oceans and so exploration in the
physical sense is it's not quite there
because you can open up your smartphone
you can look on Google Earth and you can
see the world exploration that spirit is
still alive and well in the Nano sphere
and science and technology and we need
to keep that going in a sense that we
will make our planet a better place
through exploration and addressing
things like climate energy food how we
treat other humans adventure is taking
yourself out of your comfort zone so go
out there do something a little more
risky a little more challenging and see
what that brings to you you believe we
all should do that all the time
why because it makes us feel humanist
elemental get scared
and do you a cat when you're sitting in
a city like this you're ready to go back
out again to try that next adventure
we're gonna start climbing this table
I'll let you well I think it depends you
have a big adventure like Antarctica and
then it feels pretty comfortable and
nice to stay in a city or stay at home
for a while but then eventually you go
on another adventures do you feel you
have to top it do you always feel you
have to top something that you've done I
think that part of the nature of
adventure isn't necessarily topping it
it's just pushing your comfort zone in
different ways so I mean it doesn't have
to be some crazier trip it could just be
something that you're less person or you
know learning in a new way growing in a
new way
I was anchoring a morning show with John
yes you should see what happens when you
fall last couple of weeks yes when you
fall you're on 57th Street going taxi
[Laughter]
congratulations we're glad you're home
safe got jokes I like it cedar and Alex
we're glad you're home safe and sound